remake of robocop I would not buy that
for a dollar it's bad enough the new
film replaces a scathing reagan-era
satire of privatization vigilantism and
cutthroat yuppie corporate culture with
prosaic commentary about the promise
your move creep but I have some serious
doubts about how well Stargell Kinnaman
can fill Peter Weller's helmet it's not
the performance I'm worried about
Kinnaman is an excellent actor but when
Robocop's faces the moviegoers only link
to his one-time humanity there had
better be a hyper photogenic jaw peeking
out from under that visor Kidman's it's
fine
but Weller's Weller's was magnificent
perfect lips that were too plump or too
thin chin teeth philtrum or flawless Oh
give me my Kirk Douglas dimple and he'd
have the whole package and it's not just
about Chin's I also can't get past the
changes to the iconic helmet in the
original the park man part machine all
calm is hidden by a visor for two-thirds
of the movie when he removes it and we
see his human face it's like it's like
glimpsing the visit of fader at the end
of Jedi
however the hell that in this new movie
is retractable Robocop puts it on and
removes it as casually as if he's
retracting the sunroof on his 6000 su X
outrageous I get it
Hollywood pays big bucks for a bankable
star so they want to highlight his mud
that's why movies show Iron Man and
spider-man exposing their peu names
mid-battle even though no
self-respecting comic-book hero
would ever dock mask by the way that's
reason 1 million 47 thousand two hundred
and thirty two that the recent remake
Dredd is superior to the 90s Stallone
version they let Karl Urban leave the
helmet on in the remake defense noted
Hollywood I find you in violation of
superhero bylaw 3.1 section a
protagonists are to wear their signature
costumes at all times please remove or
alter this footage in post thank you for
your cooperation
what star do you think has the best lips
in Hollywood Alexander Skarsgard
Liv Tyler Tom Hardy Scarlett Johansson
let me know in the comments what's your
favorite superhero helmet I mean besides
the one from Rocketeer which is plainly
the best ever let me know what you think
is the second best superhero helmet in
the comments and subscribe to the wired
Channel